where we left off was discussing that um
to compute product of two circuits
um we need you know we need them to be
smooth and compatible and now the output
uh circuit specified the same properties
so the question where we really left up
at the very end is how do you actually
compute log of a circuit so if you have
a circuit that is smooth decomposable
and also deterministic
um as as was brought up earlier
basically when you have a log of sum
that is deterministic you can just
um turn it around Into Summer Vlogs
because only you know one term in in the
sum will actually evaluate to non-zero
um the catch here is that um to do that
what we're doing is sort of um using
this like indicators to to make sure
that one only one of the
um uh term actually evaluates to
non-zero for for any sum node
and in in the algorithm what happens is
we actually lose determinism
so to compute uh or
to represent a logarithm of a circuit in
polymer time and and with the polynomial
size output circuit we need determinism
and in the output we actually lose
determinism the output is only going to
be smooth and decomposable which is
important when we think about how we
actually want to
compose these operators
this indicator will tell you this should
just evaluate to zero and that's how you
ensure that the output is still correct
[Music]
all right so
for these uh operators that I mentioned
earlier some products
um begin power
um natural number or a real number
portions lower than uh exponent we
basically characterize water
um what are the properties we need to
compute these
um or to perform this operator
operations attractively
um and then also
if we don't have some of these
properties this is actually
um hard
I'll show that people later so basically
oh yeah sure so
even that you don't need any
or
so there yeah so
plus this is if you just
um cared about taking some of the
circuits without actually
imposing any property and they output
right so if you can just trivially in
introduce a new song when you have a
check it means that you need this
condition and
in the output
so we actually have a separate table
that tells you both the input and output
conditions
um
yeah so so kind of referring to that
table what we can do is is now
um this pipeline view resource
um earlier right so from here we can say
you can see that okay to to perform
integration we need the circuit to be
smooth and decomposable
um and this circuit s is an output of a
product operation
which means to perform that product we
need these two circuits to be smoothing
composable and also compatible and keep
keep going uh stack right so so now what
we
um know is is this output here or is
actually an output of the log operation
meaning
we need this initial input Q to be also
deterministic
and in the table we also show that when
you have some optional like additional
properties there will be uh
preserved so in this case we we also
need um we can say logarithm preserves
compatibility so we wanted these two to
be compatible
um so the property we actually need is
is p and Q to also be compatible
um
so that's how we can kind of derive
um say if you're interested in Computing
the cross entropy these are the
properties you will need on the input
circuits
okay so I suppose I actually forgot to
add this like second table I mentioned
um we had like
similar results here but instead of um
on the queries
here we have the uh in the paper we have
this table
um that
for for every operator we were
considering
it tells you the input conditions you
need and then output properties that's
going to be guaranteed once you have
those input conditions and also
optionally when you have additional
properties which ones will actually be
preserved
um and then you can also refer to the
table of when some operate operator
would be hard
when you don't have a certain property
um so for example actually trying to
compute the logarithm without
determinism
um is actually NP hard
um and then from that week we can also
derive these tractability conditions for
all of these different information
Theory to queries exactly just following
the pipeline uh view maybe
um so earlier with the cross entropy
example
instead of having to look at each of
these uh each of these queries
individually and try to come up with a
sort of custom ad hoc algorithm for each
what we can actually do is is use this
operators to implement them really
really quickly
oh yeah of course same same
um of hardness results you know when you
don't have for example like the term
determinism many of these um diversions
queries become hard and so on
Yeah so basically
um if once you've implemented each of
these little operators like questions
logarithm product and so on
then actually implementing an inference
algorithm for any of these
um information Theory requires becomes
very easy it's just you're you're
looking at you know what you look at the
definition of the query look see what
the pipeline should look like and just
you know write them out calling to the
you know operators we defined
um so of course we you kind of use this
information theoretic quantity as as
like example to Showcase how you can
quickly come up with
um trackable algorithms
um using this compositional operations
View
but you can imagine
um you can compose these middle
operators for for different kinds of
queries
um so I want to um kind of highlight few
examples
um where we can actually apply this
composition of circuit operations idea
um if you could have examples like
applications in machine learning and
also
um comes up in and of causal effect
estimation
so um
one example I think a lot of like
um like machine learning deep learning
people would be interested in is
actually
enforcing some uh
um enforcing logical constraints on like
outputs of on your network I think a lot
um nowadays A lot of people like talk
about neurosymbolic learning and
reasoning
so all kind of just uh
go through these like really quick
basically imagine if you have a problem
where um you're trying to for example in
this case um make predictions about
about the um
a path from one point to another maybe
like minimizing a cost or um
so in that case
what what happens is is you kind of
break it down into into a discrete
problem where you're like predicting
each Edge at a time for instance
so that doesn't guarantee that the
output will actually be a path
um so this is like when you're trying to
make predictions
um and you have some structure about
your output another example could be
like when you're doing to
um multi-label classification where on
the labels you you want some structure
to be true
so all this is kind of detailed but
basically
um the problem is that a lot of new um
neural network a lot of deep learning
methods just like struggle to actually
satisfy these constraints we also saw an
example earlier
um with uh gelato and and kind of the um
language regeneration with these uh
logical constraints
um we'll quickly what we could do is
um
to do is if um if you compile kind of
the con constraint you have in the
domain as a logical circuit
um what you can do is is
um so this is your constraint circuit
that's going to be a logical circuit
um and then some circuit
that that can is connected to a to a
neural network so this is sort of the
um
probability distribution that you're you
know your network is is telling you
about the uh um the prediction labels
so what happens is
um because we can perform
um
multiplication of two circuits given for
example compatible circuits if you
compile logical circuits in in such two
um
in in a way that's actually
that can be compatible with
these uh problems because again circuit
you have
you can take those products meaning
you're sort of
um you're kind of restraining your
prediction uh space to just the ones
that actually satisfy that logical
formula
um
spiritual a lot of like details of like
what actually happens in the product and
how this gets integrated into the
training really really the um takeaway
is that you can use this trackable
product to actually enforce
um
enforce logical constraints given by a a
logical circuit
um in a way that makes it you know like
really easy to integrate it into kind of
a the whole like deep learning pipeline
um so you can
um for example train train them all end
to end because you can also
differentiate through a circuit
so you take an existing complicated
neural network architecture you drain it
and then from that time you train a
probabilistic circle the test is nice
property so you first train this network
then you train another Network and then
you have this nice properties so what
happens is actually
it's all getting trained together so
like the idea is that you have a logical
circuit you already know um the
constraint that you want to satisfy so
that that is what's given as a
background knowledge for the domain so
given that constraint you want to train
in your network in such a way that that
the outputs would would actually satisfy
that constraint
um so just how how do you turn the last
date
so what happens is actually it you can
always think of it as like a circuit
that had or a neural network and then a
circuit added at the very last layer
right so so it takes inputs from the
neural network
s of tuning to I mean you need to have
something that looks like you're
probably privacy circuits with a right
uh
you have a choice of this very last
layer like this last layer on top of the
circuit that you're adding
um so what happens is like all
everything like so when you have an
input it all gets like pass through the
neural network and then the circuits
here you build a new new layer and you
train it uh with inputs the inputs of
the
uh the Supreme state
very simple way because you choose a
probabilistic circuit queue that's
compatible with your logically
constraint
structure is fixed and you let the
neural network predict its parameters
okay
so that's one example of using this
product of two circuits
so this way um you're actually
guaranteed to get
um predictions that are consistent with
your logical constraint
um another example so this is some kind
of very general right so
uh um a very sort of simple pipeline is
is taking a product of two circuits and
then just Computing
um the integration of that output which
is just
um Computing you know expectations right
so if
um you know if there's any given
function p is your your distribution
given as a circuit
so this computes the um expectation of
that function according to this
distribution
if f is given as a circuit or you can
turn it into a compatible circuit
um easily then we can compute this with
expected prediction task also um
trackably
so where is this actually useful
um
one example
um that kind of people care about in
machine learning is when you have when
you're trying to kind of make
predictions and you have partial
observations
so of course for for us you know like so
far we were talking about like marginals
and all these different kind of queries
where you would have like partial
observations but um often given any like
classification or or a prediction model
they assume that you're given value for
all um all the variables that you've
defined
um and often how people kind of handle
partial observation and in that case is
kind of guess
in in some smart way value for for each
of those like variables with missing
values and just run it through whatever
class classifier or regression model you
have
so what we showed here was um instead of
this way of
um replacing these missing values and
then and then running them through your
prediction model
we could actually talk about
okay what is the expected output of this
classifier or regression model with
respect to some distribution over all
the all the features right so we're
saying we have some partial observations
um
if you were to
consider all the completions of of those
missing variables and and
considered the output of your prediction
model
um with respect to the you know how how
those
um
how those partial uh
what what the probability of those
partial assignments are what is the
actual expected value I would see
um so this we can
um compute you know attractively in some
simple cases of classifiers and and
regression models um you can also you
use that
um
it's all to to kind of
Define functions that can be represented
as circuits to some kind of
generalization of like decision trees or
or simplest
um sort of linear regression that's a
circuit version of it so in those cases
we can compute this exactly and and
actually
um
you know get get really kind of good
missing value predictions
um one one last thing
um kind of
uh talk a lot about and like machine
learning is also like or or these models
bias are these models they're some kind
of simplest notion of of fairness that
people have uh defined essentially turns
into like an expectation
um problem you know comparing like
expected value for different demographic
groups which you can also uh compute
easily
um
with circuits
so one um last
example that I I want to focus on more
is actually
um
estimating causal effects so in this
case suppose we have
um so the variables variable set X and
given some sub subsets who are
interested in in what the causal effect
of
um so what what the probability of Y
will be if you intervene on
um variables a so here here Y and a or
disjoint that's the variables
of course in general
um correlation is not causation so this
is not the same as the conditional
probabilities
um we saw so far
so in
um sort of causal inference
this is what you would have is is kind
of if you're given
um some kind of assumptions or some
knowledge of of your causal structure
then that tells you
um that gives you formulas to
um
to actually estimate this this to
yeah
um estimate this uh effect after this
two operator operation
so in this case for instance
um in this example that's that's called
a back door
um so the backdoor formula for for this
structure is is given here so this is an
example where you have some confounder
variable
um as as well as an effect from this um
from from a to the outcome y
um and then also another example
um with again the the formula given for
for this uh causal effect and if you
look at this now um this kind of gets
um composed into
[Music]
you know taking like conditional
distribution of your distribution or to
concrete marginals and then you know
summing them over taking quotient and so
on so you could
imagine some of these might might reuse
um the like operators redefined earlier
right taking products
taking taking quotient of some two
circuits or functions
um so
it's a little bit more detail so
considering this um backdoor query we
saw
earlier
um think that
benches over here so also feel free to
like jump in if I'm missing any detail
or if I'm like Mis
um explaining it
um so
if this distribution p is given as a
circuit that's not just
um it's not just trackable for you know
um marginalism map but it's actually
even structurally composable for some
unspecified V3 this query is still um
sharply hard to compute right
so how do we actually
um handle this kind of causal inference
well we're going to use this idea of
compositional operations and then think
about what are the properties we need
for this like input and outputs to to
this operation
so um here here's the the pipeline for
the um Vector query
um
so for instance what gets involved is is
this uh marginalization as an operator
so now now instead of computing a
marginal
um probability for some particular
partial uh instance now what we're doing
doing is actually
um
trying to get another circuit that
represents a marginal distribution over
some subset of variables right so this
is kind of um analogous to like
forgetting and logical circuits if
you're familiar
um
and then product we've seen before same
marginal um
operator
and here this kind of uh conditional
is actually also another pipeline using
the operators we've seen so far right so
the main
um the new operator here is actually
doing this marginalization and what's
the property
um you get and and you need for the
input and outputs here
okay
yeah so yeah um
yes the issue here is that you need to
communicate for the power operation
um you know as sort of was in the atlas
but
um if you apply marginalization to a
deterministic circuit the output is no
longer necessarily deterministers so if
you see on this left side yeah it's
great to provide Foundation operation
and then a power
um and so yeah
the property you need
right so we don't quite hear you
oh yeah so I can I think uh repeat it so
basically we we um have this power uh
really like an inverse operator and
referring back to the advanced
composition of operations
um table to compute this inverse of a
circuit we need the input to this in um
to be deterministic well what is the
input to
this um operator well the output of
marginalization of a circuit P right so
the problem here is even if this
initials are the key is deterministic
um after marginalization
um might no longer be determined
you know
so now we need a way to somehow express
it and guarantee that after
marginalization you can feed it into the
power operator meaning if you want some
property about this initial circuit that
would guarantee us uh determinism after
marginalization
and
um
in an obvious way the property is called
marginal determinism meaning essentially
meaning if you look at a
a subset of variables the
so
yeah so it's kind of defined in terms of
the the initial circuit and the um
partial assignments that you can feed
into a circuit but one way to
essentially think about this is that
once you've
um marginalized out all the variables so
that you only have
um
only have q left the resulting circuit
is
um deterministic so that's a way to
think about marginal determining or Q
determinism particularly
or kind of um
yeah so this is essentially just kind of
um coming from coming straight from the
the definition right so so we've defined
in such a way that once you marginalize
out all the variables but Q then the
resulting circuit is uh deterministic if
you started out with a Q determining
circuit
basically
um
going back to this picture
right
so so now we kind of have a language to
express
um what what properties we need for this
um initial circuits basically coming
from marginal determinism with respect
to particular subsets of variables
then you can do the same same exercise
of of starting from what you need at the
very last output going through your
pipeline in backwards order to
um to to come up with what the input
conditions are for your initial circuit
so and then given given um this marginal
determinism property we can actually
compute this backdoor query in in uh
polynomial time
okay and then here are some um open
questions that that Benji has kind of
sort of uh
suggested right so
um yeah so so one example is are are all
of these um
for the queries
um
actually trackable and
yeah for for some circuit uh property
that we can Define
and what yeah yeah so like we saw the
back door and then we also saw the
napkin
um some example of a formula right so
actually
um both of these you can do in in
polynomial time but yeah there was other
other specific words other graphs which
might lead to to other Expressions which
um
yeah and basically like um yeah what's
the what's the optimal complexity for
for these like different kinds of
queries
um
Okay so
hopefully that gives you a picture of of
some more exciting queries that we can
uh compute officially and and what
conditions we need for that and how to
derive those conditions
um and next he will talk to you about
um
the question that was hinted at very in
the very beginning are all trackable
distributions actually you know proper
circuits or can be represented in
circuits
um all right so I know we've covered a
lot of ground and it's been a long day
but I I try to save this really really
neat fun thing for last I really enjoyed
this myself
um and also I saved it for last because
now that you're all sold on Pro six
circuits being the end-all be-all of
prostic reasoning I'll show you that
they cannot do everything and which we
need more and whatever and there will be
some interesting connections to Circuit
lower bounds
uh probability Theory and so uh you know
I I hope this is a a fun way to end and
then you're looking later in the slides
look up all the machine learning details
uh before I get into the fun stuff I
have some uh basic bookkeeping which is
I promise to tell you that there's you
know all of these other models
historically that we all just call
prostic circuits as an umbrella term and
I do owe you a little bit of a more uh
thorough overview there so this might be
a bit boring at this point but I do want
to kind of give credit to all this
original work that proposed some new
circuit language in some syntax with
properties like decomposability and so
on in order to do prostic inference so
arithmetic circuits are very well known
some product networks which are more
focusing on the learning side but
there's a whole bunch of other ones and
if you ever wonder uh you know what are
these things and I don't really want to
dive into all the details and figure out
myself so here's an overview of you know
saying a some product network is smooth
and decomposable pro 6 circuit but it's
usually not deterministic when you see
an arithmetic circuit in the literature
it's always deterministic because it's
been compiled as such and so here you
can figure out also that a bunch of
other representations in the literature
actually have this structure
decomposability property that allows you
to then compute things like Gale
Divergence entropy and so on okay so
this is here mostly to give credit to
all of the original proposals and here
on these slides later you can figure out
well if I have a graphical model then it
has these properties and then by now you
know exactly what query classes are
tractable you can do this for graphical
models arithmetic circuits they're
really very similar to the pro 6 circuit
syntax we showed before except the
parameters are given as separate inputs
they're not given on the edges
some product networks syntactically look
identical to what we showed you so they
were one of the later proposals in this
family cut set networks look very
different but they end up kind of being
like bdds followed by three shade
graphical models by now it should be
clear that these are just probosik
circuits and there's a few other things
like probosite sentential decision
diagrams prosec decision graphs and or
graphs
and so you know credits to all of that
original work
but now the the final question that I'm
kind of excited about as a fun
theoretical exercise is
um well okay Pro six circuits somehow
they cover all of this stuff that we
know how to compute tractable marginals
in so I'll focus on marginal
probabilities for now right all of the
stuff with low trivets all of the other
representations with model counting on
circuits it's all is it everything are
there distributions that we actually
know uh how to compute marginal
probabilities for that somehow do not
have a probabilistic circuit
representation okay or is this like the
universal language of all things
tractable for marginals and so this
question was uh um occupying me for a
while and specifically I always had this
uh counter example in mind which is
called the determinental point process
it's quite popular in theory uh
probability Theory but it's also quite
popular in machine learning as a model
of uh for example you know baskets of
Amazon shopping uh you know this is
typically how you model distributions
over you know people's behavior where
um well I'll get to this in in a second
but essentially the way that they're
defined is you're given some matrix it's
called an L Ensemble and if I would like
to know the probability of a particular
world for example a world where one X1
is set to one X3 is set to one and
everything else is set to zero then I
just take the first and the third row
and column I get the sub Matrix and I
compute its determinants okay this
determinants up to a normalizing
constant gives me exactly the
probability of this world the likelihood
so this tells you how to compute the
likelihood the probability of a complete
assignment but there's actually some
really neat math that will tell you how
to turn this L Ensemble with some
efficient linear algebra into another
Matrix where you can now compute
marginal probabilities
okay and so this is actually a
distribution that is tractable for
computing marginals but the way that you
compute the marginals is by Computing
determinants okay
um the reason why we care is
um well they're tractable models just a
bunch of determinants and they have this
nice property called Global negative
dependence so as I make more variables
be true it becomes less likely that the
other variables are true okay and so
this is very intuitive if you think of
shopping right if you buy a screen for
your computer it's very likely you'll
buy a second screen and even most likely
you'll buy a third one right so there's
kind of this negative dependence that
prefers kind of sparse sets as Solutions
yeah so these have applications and
recommendation systems
and so the question we had a couple
years ago was
um well okay we have this gigantic
language of probabilistic circuits that
are decomposable it includes all
boundary with graphical models and then
we have these dpps and we don't really
know how they fit in this picture Okay
um
well we already know that there are
certain distributions that are both
efficiently represented as circuits and
as dpps
the trivial ones just an independent
coin flip for every item it's
essentially a an L Ensemble that's a
diagonal matrix where you if your
computer determinant you just multiply
the diagonal elements okay so that's
easy the real question is is there
something here is there a detrimental
Point process distribution that is
tractable yet it doesn't have a
probabilistic circuit okay
um and we tried to prove this for
various types of robustic circuits and
I'll spare you some of the less
interesting theorems but essentially if
you have a bunch of properties like
structure determinism
um structure decomposability a
determinism
Etc it's very easy to prove that you
cannot write a DPP determinal purposes
in as a probabilistic circuit
um the interesting result here is that
if you have somehow the most General
language I showed you that still
supports marginals meaning
probosik circuits with you know positive
parameters for the mixtures and only
decomposability then somehow you can
prove that actually there does not exist
a determental point process
representation in this language
um I want to mention an open problem
which you might want to think about but
it's probably too difficult uh which is
if you allow negative mixtures where you
say I create a mixture model with some
probability of five and another one of
-4 right if you allow for negative
probabilities on the edges of your
probabilistic circuit then we don't
actually know
if it can represent dpps and so this is
something you might think about yeah
even those who
uh
foreign
exclusion and the whole question of q9qw
it's all related but yeah maybe it will
be more clear at the end yeah
okay so how do we prove this well we
don't really prove this this was
actually a result that kind of fell out
of originally the arithmetic circuit
lower bound literature so worked by Russ
and yehudayov where essentially they
prove there exists what's called a
multilinear arithmetic circuit I think
it's also called monotone that cannot
represent certain functions including
the uniform distribution over spanning
trees and so it turns out that the
uniform distribution over spanning trees
so so what is this this is you have a
Boolean variable for every Edge in let's
say the complete graph and you would
like to have that there's a probability
of zero for all uh choices of
assignments to such variables except for
the ones that correspond to a spanning
tree in the graph
okay
um and let's say that we want a uniform
distribution over those non-zero things
all right so it turns out that yeah this
distribution actually is a detrimental
Point process so it's tractable
however
folks have shown that any
decomposable Pro 6 circuit
representation has to have a size of at
least 2 to the N over thirty thousand
okay
so this is a you know a rare event where
we have an unconditional lower bounds
and it directly applies to this question
like Dan is going to ask something
um all right so that's exciting
um
and we now know that yeah spanning tree
distributions are not representable by
the PCS I've shown you and they are dpps
okay
uh so let's fix this let's come up with
a
one circuit language to rule them all
let's come up with one representation
that can represent all tractable
distributions okay I don't want to have
the language be probabilistic circuits
Union dpps that's not very pretty right
I would like to have one representation
of everything and so this is what we
will call a probabilistic generating
circuit
um
okay so this is all inspired by the
notion of a generating function a
probability generating function which is
a very well known thing in probability
Theory and I'm sure made theoreticians
in this room have used generating
functions as a ways of proving
properties about distributions
the only thing that we will do that's
interesting here is say this is not just
a mathematical object to prove a theorem
this is actually a data structure that
we will use to represent things in a
computer and compute probabilities okay
that's the only leap we make here and so
here's the idea um so a generating
function represents a distribution by so
by the way everything is binary here
right it's convenient
um the way that it does so is by
associating a monomial with every
possible world and the monomial has all
of the Z variables that are set to true
in that particular world so here all
variables were set to true and test
probability Point 16 so this monomial Z1
Z2 Z3 has a a coefficient of 0.60 okay
the world where everything's false has
probability uh two percent okay
um now what's really neat here is um you
know typically when you think of
generating functions you think of them
as these multilinear functions but you
can also uh just factorize them and this
is an equivalent way of writing uh this
particular generating function
of course you see where I'm going
uh what I would like to do is write
these things as circuits okay I would
like to write them as circuits that are
sums of products of sums of products of
these variables Z indicating which world
am I in and uh some constants that
somehow Define what are the coefficients
of these monomials
so this circuit here is just identical
to my original multilinear function it's
just a different way of writing it
okay now there is a purpose to all of
this oh I should also mention if I would
like to take a probabilistic circuit
and turn it into a generating function
it's quite easy to do so so a pro 6
circuit over Boolean random variables
you can also think of it as being this
type of
multilinear function where you have this
leaf or these input distribution saying
X is true X1 is true X2 is true X3 is
true or X1 is 2 true X2 is true X3 is
false right so this is kind of telling
you what is the what are the literals
that are represented by my probabilistic
circuits
okay and then you have all of the
coefficients which are all of the
parameters on the on the sub nodes that
get
arithmetically combined together
and if I need to turn this type of
function into a generating function it's
pretty easy I just need to take all of
the positive literals and turn them into
these Z variables and I have to take all
the negative literals and turn them into
the number one
okay and that means that I can take a
probabilistic circuit with 500 million
edges and I just replace all X1 by Z1
all not x one by one and now I have a
probability generating circuits a
processing generating circuit that looks
like this okay
all right so I know how to get hold of
these things for any pro 6 circuit but
the whole point of this exercise is I
would like to be able to compute
marginals efficiently okay and I would
like to compute likelihoods so if I
somehow get hold of this generating
function as a circuit how do I compute a
marginal right our previous algorithm no
longer applies because it's a different
kind of function right it only has these
Z variables it doesn't have these input
distributions anymore right well so
here's a very cute way of computing a
probability so suppose I care about
Computing a marginal probability where a
bunch of variables X are set to true
a bunch of other variables X are set to
false and all the other variables are
unknown I marginalize them out of the
distribution okay so what I can do is
um every exit is required to be true
replace it by some purely symbolic
variable t
okay every X is that's set to false I
replace by zero and all of the other
variables Z are replaced by the constant
one okay now I can evaluate my circuits
and I end up just taking sums and
products of polynomials in t all right
at the output of my circuit I get some
polynomial in t
agreed
and so now here's how you decode this
polynomial into a marginal probability
all of the monomials where I set
variables to true that must be false by
my query
they all get multiplied by zero they are
removed from my equation
okay so those monomials disappear from
the the expression
all of the other monomials they all get
added up to become this polynomial in t
now only the monomials that set all of
the required variables to true they will
have the maximum degree
the one that said everything to true
that needs to be set to true all the
other ones they will miss some of the
variables that are required to be true
in my query
if you sum all of those up
the coefficient here this is my marginal
probability of that query
okay
let me give you an example
okay so bottom line is the the leading
coefficient here of this polynomial and
T will give me exactly the marginal
probability that I would like to query
here's an example I would like to know
what's the probability that X2 is true
and X3 is false marginalizing out X1
uh I set
C3 uh to zero
um I said Z1 to 1 Z2
T okay I compute my
polynomial and I get 0.16 t plus
0.02 I don't really care about 0.02 what
I care about is the 0.16 because this is
exactly the probability I'm looking for
it's this marginal probability summing
these two uh world's probabilities
okay so what we have here is a
completely different circuit language
it's not a prostic circuit in the sense
that I defined it earlier
but it's also a tractable language for
marginalization I can in polynomial time
get any marginal out of this
distribution
all right
um
so the algorithm I just described to you
has this complexity you need to multiply
and add a bunch of polynomials which has
this complexity uh it's all polynomial
Maybe
should I should I give more details yeah
so so this is the for M edges and N
random variables
um so we need to compute this uh we have
to propagate essentially these end
degree polynomials through our circuit
um which this complexity if you do it
naively and here you just use the
Fourier transform to multiply the
um the polynomials
so that's efficient but you can actually
do better so there was actually a paper
that just came out last month where
people showed that there's a simpler way
to do this you just re-evaluate your
circuit end times with different values
for T and you compute the polynomial
interpolation to get this m times n
complexity to compute a marginal
probability
slicer okay
um good
so this is nice these probabilistic
generating circuits they're tractable
but there's a caveat which is well okay
there's kind of a positive and a
negative interpretation of this I
haven't mentioned anything about
decomposability or syntactic
multilinearity or any other properties
because there are no properties this
circuit has no local thing that is
required to be true for you to compute a
marginal any circuit that represents a
generating polynomial will be tractable
no matter how you represent it okay so
that's nice you don't really have to
worry about these local syntactic
properties the downside is if I give you
a circuit actually checking that it
represents a multilinear function now
becomes hard in fact NP hard so you kind
of have this Global property of the
function that's hard to know so you have
to somehow trust it by construction
whatever circuit I give you is actually
representing a generating polynomial
um okay so back to our problem of
determental Point processes
because
generating functions are so well studied
in theory we know exactly what is the
generating polynomial for a determinable
point process it's this one here
um so this is the expression it's
telling you build a diagonal matrix of
these Z variables that are part of my
polynomial
uh multiplied by this L Ensemble this
Matrix of parameters
uh at I determinant okay
um so now we have to take this
expression which is just a mathematical
expression and turn it into a circuit
that is efficient in the number of
random variables a compact circuits okay
um so this is how you do it first part
is easy this is just a constant that
does not depend on Z so you just
pre-compute it this is just a number
and then we need to somehow get hold of
a circuit representation of this
determinant computation that only uses
sums and products because that's how we
defined the circuit language
and in the literature again you can find
some really nice division free
determinant algorithms uh Samuelson
Berkowitz is one choice you can make and
now you can actually get hold of a
circuit representation of your
determinental point process in
polynomial time and with obviously
polynomial size
um
so this is neat now we have a language
that captures all proposing circuits all
determantle Point processes
um if you actually do this from a
machine learning perspective it also you
can also train these models from data
and actually get state of the art
likelihoods on some of these benchmarks
question yeah so it's a bit artificial
the way probably think circuits are
encoded in two things
what do you mean with artificial
I I mean you cannot do the same kind of
thing that you were doing on PCS on pgcs
you can right
you can you can still do all of this
which is your representation so this
pgcs are in general not decomposable
they're just any circuit but they also
still allow you to compute a marginal
that's the video yeah but if you want to
do other things then like oh no one has
even thought about Computing other
queries on these things so so you just
you're just a way to
have a common way to compute marginal
and that's all that's right so what is
the simplest language that captures all
trackable processing models well okay
this is at least a proposal that
captures both of these things in a very
simple circuit language
[Music]
yeah
that like module is actually faster yeah
that's a good point if you do this
translation this happens to be
the evaluation from end times and to
just and I think
but but you could just take the original
PCM
there's nothing to be gained here but
what you would like is to be able to
express distributions that you couldn't
Express I suppose
yeah so this is just showing that it's a
student species
okay
um
I feel like we're pretty tired at this
point so let me just hand wave through
the next part and then I think we're
done
um
so the reason why people study uh
generating polynomials is to prove
theorems about distributions for example
um people like to prove properties such
as distributions being strongly Rayleigh
you'll find a lot of interesting Theory
literature on that and so this really
means that the the
that the complex Roots have this
constraint that they cannot have a
positive imaginary part and so you
wonder why is this interesting well it
happens to be true of these dpps
and it kind of implies that whenever we
have this specific property that you can
actually sample efficiently from the
distribution if you build a Gibb sampler
of a certain type it's provably in
polynomial polynomial time going to uh
converge to the stationary distribution
so what this property tells you is you
know if this polynomial has certain
types of roots then it's sufficient to
sample from okay and sampling is of
course an approximate inference
algorithm but you know this is why
people care about these representations
because now you can build provably
efficient samplers
um here's a statement of the sampling
theorem which we'll skip so a natural
next question is well we have uh bgcs
they allow for exact marginals to be
computed efficiently we have strongly
really distributions which allow for
sampling to be done efficiently dpps are
in the middle and so are there
generating circuits that are efficient
for
computing marginals but don't have the
strongly really property and are there
distributions that are efficient to
sample from that are intractable for
computing marginals okay and so
um the answer is yes this is a trivial
generating polynomial where the roots
are you know I and I and so therefore
it's not strongly really yet it's a very
small probabilistic generating function
and it can be used to compute marginals
efficiently so that's a very simple
counter example A Discounter example is
a or separating example or whatever you
want to call it is a bit trickier so you
can check this paper from last month
um actually encoding some very general
form of a relaxation of bipartite
matching into a generating polynomial
um I'll spare you the details but
essentially uh what they're able to show
here is that yeah there is a generating
polynomial that has this property that
it's real stable meaning it has this
strongly really efficient sampling
property and that's also Sharpie hard to
actually exactly evaluate marginals in
and so this is a counter example there
are some very interesting details in
this proof like it's somewhat
non-trivial because you have to make
sure that this polynomial represents a
distribution so no negative coefficients
and so on but you can check the work
later and so here's the statement of the
theorem so if P to the sharp E is not in
P slash poly then this particular
generating polynomial has no PGC
that's compact
all right so then this is the picture
we're left with
and I mean this is all very recent work
in the last I mean the pgcs were only
proposed two years ago and all of the
other follow-up workers from this summer
so um I think there's a lot to be done
for people that like generating
functions and polynomials to understand
really the landscape here and at least
today I'm not aware of any distribution
over binary random variables that is
efficient to compute marginals in that
does not have a small prostate
generating circuits and so maybe someone
can tell me one or prove that this is
the universal language of all tractable
distributions
and that's really it uh I hope I gave
you some interesting problems here to
think about and again check the slides
for how to actually do the machine
learning here
I think we can we can look that up
offline thanks okay thank you again
so questions
how do you even check that a multi
multi-linear polynomial satisfies are
really really
um criteria
good question I I do have an example of
one that obviously satisfies this
um I do but I don't think it will help
you this one this one is strongly really
but I don't really know how to to argue
that for any Matrix yeah so this one
does not have for any Matrix l
um that is an L Ensemble so there's I
guess some constraints there on like
positivity and so on and rank maybe
um there are no complex roots of this
polynomial that have a positive
imaginary part yeah okay I'm convinced
um smarter people than me can probably
easily tell you why
is hung
Ry
[Music]
um that's a good question
um so usually when you do this when you
let's say take some input computer
that marginals over other variables give
them as input to the next promo stick
model this actually breaks all
tractability and in fact in the Deep
learning World there are models
currently that are very hyped up called
State space models where you essentially
do this you have the type of almost like
a Markov chain that you do inference on
by essentially multiplying matrices for
a long time you get some output you fit
that in us into the next Markov chain
and you do this 100 times so so what
you're suggesting is actually being
trained right now in the Deep learning
world to build new language models but
the tractability goes away
you can just
yeah
so you you saw me on the probably six
seconds being the right tool for
neurosembly computation or combining
neural network and uh and logical
constraints uh is there something hidden
I mean
is that case is actually where it is not
the right tool for it or
um there are some cases where it's not
so easy for example
um
the word that YouTube showed is saying
the distribution has to be appropistic
circuit and then we can inverse the
constraints so that's fine as long as
their constraint has a practical form
otherwise you find some over under
approximation you know how to do that it
gets trickier when your distribution has
to be like gpt24 right so then you don't
have a probabilistic circuit for it and
you still would like to enforce
constraints and so there what we're
currently working on is using proposing
circuits as approximations so you have
to build a bit more complex Machinery to
them be able to use these ideas to
enforce constraints of arbitrary
autoregressive models and stuff like
that yeah it gets a bit more complicated
okay Remy maybe that's the last question
so I have a question for earlier by
usual so I think it's uh 52.16 or
something so there was a picture of
putting uh certain on top of on top of
that
next one
right so here you are so T is the neural
network and then you feed it into your
circuit yeah can you just throw it in
your own network away and they used to
use I'll use data to train your circuit
like they work
um that's conditioned on the function uh
so this is kind of a weight
um
do like
um have a conditional version of pieces
where you can um condition comes from
a bit of a single sort of um
distribution over the labels now now
this is depending on
other inputs and and you use
this better than your network and that
changes the distribution over labels
you're trading at the same time yeah
you're creating everything
also technically you could learn a joint
distribution over Y and Z and some I'll
be that the one circuit but then usually
your conditional distribution wouldn't
be as good as if you just use a neural
network to
read Z and spit out the parameters of
the prostate circuits because if you
always know that you're going to observe
the inputs of your neural network
there's no need to learn joint
distribution over them you're kind of
wasting capacity
and that's part of your question
yeah this is I guess yeah specifically
because you care about this conditional
not really other queries from The Joint
District
okay so let's thank the speakers once
again
and
before you go I'd like to remind you
that on Thursday we have the town town
hall meeting uh please join us uh right
after the the regular program is 4 45
and this is when we discuss what we want
to do during the the remaining uh four
months here uh do we want to have
reading groups do we have to have
impromptu talks do we have to we have
what do we want to do what what are the
open Pro uh anything that relates to the
organization of the uh of The Institute
of this program I should say uh this is
what we're planning to discuss on
Thursday so make sure you are there so
you can you can hear your opinion
okay we resume tomorrow at the usual
time 9 30 and coffee nine o'clock
okay